si recientemente recibió tratamiento por
un ataque cardíaco una afección
provocada por un bloqueo del flujo
sanguíneo hasta su músculo cardíaco este
vídeo le ayudará a comprender la
afección y su tratamiento el corazón es
un órgano muscular encargado de bombear
sangre que contiene el oxígeno y los
nutrientes que su cuerpo necesita la
principal cámara de bombeo de su corazón
es el ventrículo izquierdo cuando el
ventrículo izquierdo se contrae envía
sangre rica en oxígeno a su cuerpo a
través de una gran arteria llamada aorta
conectadas a la aorta hay pequeñas
arterias llamadas arterias coronarias
y la sangre fluye desde la aorta a
través de las arterias coronarias para
suministrar oxígeno y nutrientes al
músculo cardíaco
durante un ataque cardíaco es posible
que se haya reducido gravemente el flujo
de sangre a través de una de las
arterias coronarias o que se haya
bloqueado por completo la reducción del
flujo de sangre puede ser causada por
una acumulación de una sustancia grasa
llamada placa en las arterias coronarias
si se rompe esta placa se pueden formar
coágulos sanguíneos y empeorar
gravemente la estrechez o causar un
bloqueo completo repentino que haga que
deje de fluir sangre desde la arteria un
bloqueo en las arterias coronarias
impidió que el oxígeno y los nutrientes
de la sangre lleguen a la parte del
corazón suministrada por la arteria como
resultado el músculo cardíaco de esa
área comenzó a morir el daño de la parte
del músculo cardíaco se denomina ataque
cardíaco también se lo conoce como
infarto de miocardio
y emme es posible que el médico
cardiólogo le haya recomendado un
procedimiento para ayudarle a abrir el
bloqueo y mejorar el flujo sanguíneo
hasta el área dañada
es posible que el procedimiento que tuvo
haya sido una angioplastia coronaria
durante una angioplastia coronaria un
catéter con punta de globo se infla
dentro de la arteria coronaria bloqueada
para abrirla el procedimiento pudo haber
incluido la colocación de un stent para
ayudar a mantener la arteria abierta
esto es por lo general una malla de
metal delgada que actúa como una cánula
o posiblemente haya tenido un injerto de
bypass de la arteria coronaria o v ac y
ve hace es un procedimiento quirúrgico
en el que se rodean las áreas bloqueadas
de las arterias coronarias con venas u
otras arterias del cuerpo
antes de salir del hospital es muy
posible que su proveedor de atención
médica le haya recetado varios
medicamentos
su medicación podría incluir lo
siguiente
la terapia antiplaquetaria oral ayuda a
evitar que las plaquetas se unan y
formen nuevos coágulos sanguíneos
también es probable que haya recibido
fármacos llamados beta bloqueadores que
ayudan a disminuir el ritmo cardíaco y
la presión sanguínea los fármacos como
los inhibidores de la enzima
convertidora de angiotensina o s/a
bloqueadores receptores de angiotensina
o beherea y bloqueadores del canal de
calcio también funcionan para disminuir
la presión sanguínea en caso de ser
necesario y posiblemente se le hayan
recetado estatinas junto con una dieta
reducida en grasas para disminuir el
colesterol estos fármacos reducen la
cantidad de colesterol formado en el
hígado
es importante que siga tomando los
medicamentos según se lo recete el
médico
incluso si se está sintiendo mejor no
deje de tomar la medicación a menos que
se lo indique el profesional médico que
se los recetó